former president Trump on a seemingly
Unstoppable pass to the GOP nomination
and has got the liberal media and
Democrats throwing everything and the
kitchen sink to try and stop his
momentum James Carville you remember him
he would like the media to stop treating
Trump like a normal
candidate and there's a massive effort
to normalize this you see the New York
Times columns say well the Trump people
have a case you see the head of JP
Morgan Chase the largest bank in the
United States saying well they they're
right about some things you see report
with Jason Miller in the Fort De mo
hotel reminds me of a bunch of German
reporters in some Munich the bar in 1935
saying hey Goring he was an entertaining
guy I tell you what he had some great
stories nothing is normal about this at
all and Nancy Pelosi is attacking
Trump's mental Fitness accusing the
former prison of having cognitive
disorder but then she herself got
confused I'm not going to spend too to
much time on Donald Trump's uh cognitive
disorders he tried to say that Nikki
Haley did not allow the National Guard
to come but it was Nancy Pelosi it was
NE nobody it was Joe it was Donald Trump
he knows and you know that Mitch
McConnell Chuck Schumer and I begged for
hours for the National Guard to come all
right Greg James Carville he's kind of
he just says whatever like throw it
against the wall and see it's six has no
real consequences to what he said he's
an expert in abnormal I mean him calling
anybody unhinged he's like a he's like a
human flapping screen door and a trailer
park twister whenever I hear him I think
of a chipmunk possessed who just got
into your Ridin so it's like and the
fact is what he's saying is like they're
trying to flip the script apparently on
mental Fitness but they wrote that
script they were the first on the Block
to introduce mental Fitness and Sanity
is fair game remember Trump in the 25th
Amendment they went so hard on mental
illness they actually created one for
themselves Trump derangement they just
and it's gripped everybody from CNN to
MSNBC you me you can't mention Trump
without them seizing up and some
internal seizure it's like it's like a
stun gun to their extremities when you
bring up Donald Trump I keep predicting
that this year is going to be insane
because all the previous El election
years were insane and this one might get
crazier but maybe I'm wrong maybe it's
just these people right right when you
remove these people from the equation
maybe you know cuz they've blown their
WAD for years on this stuff and nobody
outside their bubble takes it seriously
maybe this is all that's going to happen
is just these people in America gets on
with their lives and votes Jessica do
you think that anything Carville said
was useful for democrats for a certain
subsection of Democrats and James
Carville you know he's a party Elder
right and he's responsible for one of
the more successful Democratic
presidencies in history Republicans even
like the 9s right and we all go by it's
the economy stupid and you wouldn't have
that if you didn't have James Carbell
and so that's important but the
overarching point he's making about the
normalization of trump is important and
when you think back to how much we
lowered the bar in the beginning we' say
like oh well he didn't mock a disabled
reporter today or he didn't mock a war
hero um or he didn't say that a woman
had blood coming out of her nose and her
whatever suddenly he's having the most
fantastic day and we have learned no
lessons about it even go back to Iowa
the coverage on Election night of the
primary and this was across the board
people saying oh he's acting so
civilized right he was being nice and
conil to her Nikki did a great job Ron
even did a good job and then 10 minutes
in he starts talking about how
immigrants are poisoning the blood of
America and then you get to New
Hampshire it's going after Nikki
insinuating that her dress is too cheap
to wear and that it's ugly how
dare yeah it was actually a nice
dress that's true I did not die from it
but it it is not something I want to
hear from someone who's going to be
president
and any day over the words mostly you
would just take interrupting me over
anything on any day the cognitive
dissonance thing is fair game though and
people want to minimize it and say well
if he has three blunders and Joe Biden
has six that that's what it is but you
know the Nikki Hae and Nancy Pelosi
Mix-Ups the magnets and water I mean
acting out missile defense systems ding
ding ding boom whoosh what kind of
President is that that's what he did
this is such an old argument weird
because it feels judg like what
Democrats did in 2016 and lost yeah you
know Carville is worried about Donald
Trump being normalized I have news for
him Donald Trump was normalized in 2020
when he was elected president of the
United States okay okay Donald Trump is
being normalized again as he is coasting
to be the candidate for the Republican
party to run again and I am sick and
tired of the Hitler uh reference who did
he kill where is the genocide you want
to talk about 13 American servicemen uh
outside at an airport in Afghanistan
while they were waiting for permission
to do a kill shot and the Biden
Administration is so clueless they
couldn't even get involved in the Rules
of Engagement to give him permission to
shoot so they died you want to talk
about killing people let's talk about
the fentanyl the drug trafficking and
what's coming through the southern
border you know you want to talk about
that how about the people the men and
women being injured in Iraq and Syria
and the Biden Administration doesn't
respond until commercial vessels are
interfered with by the houthis then all
of a sudden the Biden Administration has
a heart how much lower can we go in this
country or can the Democrats go than to
compare a president of the United States
to the most evil man in this in In Our
Lifetime and Jason Miller being a Nazi
in a Munich bar give me a break our
people have been spit on thrown out of
restaurants we they were told to get in
our faces you want to talk unhinged
vaccine Waters is unhinged so I'm sick
of there saying that we're a threat to
democracy they're a threat to my
democracy they're a threat to my first
amendment my second amendment my
religious freedoms as a parent as a
being called a domestic terrorist now
they want to put illegals in my home
let's go to the third amendment Fourth
Amendment getting our bank records
without search warrants why don't they
take the time and just say you know what
why did you vote for Donald Trump we do
every article is about instead of
instead of saying Safari stupid we're
rude and we're a bunch of Rubes you know
what the cognitive disorder here is the
mumbling bumbling Joe Biden who can't
even stand up without falling down all
right Jesse can we get your thoughts
please yeah I think Democrats are
walking into a trap on the cognition
thing I mean Trump says Nikki he means
Nancy your guy can't walk can't talk and
sees dead people Jessica why do you guys
let me understand your strategy for
defeating this guy okay it's to not
campaign not debate and then hide from
the press in the public it's to arrest
him strip his business license strip him
off the ballot then censor him when he's
on TV censor his spokesman and then
accuse him of plotting assassinations
accuse him of starting World War III the
Civil War I mean you're saying he's
going to create death camps he's going
to put Jews gays and journalists to
death you guys are out of your mind
because probably you saw that he's I
think ahead six points in the latest
Reuters poll that's probably why you're
wetting the bed and the blankets and the
throw pillows it's a good pee we had and
in that poll uh that was true and also
there were 26% undecided hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else